la nuit prochaine cela fera quinze ans
jour pour jour que le coeur atomique du
quatrième réacteur de la centrale de
tchernobyl en ukraine explosé le
combustible nucléaire brûlé pendant dix
jours expulsant des millions de
radioéléments le bilan soviétique de
l'époque plus de 31 morts et 230 7
blessés mais des données non officielles
font état aujourd'hui de 15 à 30 mille
tués le nuage radioactif issu de
tchernobyl passa sur la france à
l'époque qu'on minimise à ce passage
aujourd'hui le ministre de la santé
bernard kouchner demande une étude
épidémiologique sur un accroissement des
cancers de la thyroïde et puis les
scientifiques continuent de s'interroger
sur l'état actuel de la contamination
ainsi encore ce reportage hélène bernier
diane richard ce prélèvement de terre
permettra-t-il de connaître la vérité
quinze ans après la catastrophe de
tchernobyl l'état lance une campagne de
mesure de la radioactivité en terre
corse qui fut soi-disant épargnés par
les retombées du nuage selon des experts
ces terres seraient au contraire encore
largement contaminé ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment le résiduel
de tchernobyl ça veut dire 186 il y
avait dix fois plus de radioactivité et
en particulier de l'iode-131 de 7 831
peut aujourd'hui être un élément qui a
permis l'apparition de tous ces concerts
de théorie or la radioactivité est une
des causes connues du cancer de la
thyroïde
le poison lui est toujours là en petites
quantités mais présent partout si
légumes du jardin constantin maziane en
mange plus persuadé que son cancer est
liée à tchernobyl ça c'était surtout une
maladie de femmes qu'on faisait avant
mais là le nombre d'hommes qui ont là
la thyroïde que ce soit cancéreux ou pas
incroyable j'ai pas du tout l'intention
d'attaquer qui que ce soit je souhaite
simplement que ça ne se reproduise pas
parce qu'autrement avait choisi cette
j'ai des petits enfants qui ont vécu ici
je lentilles dans dix ou quinze à vingt
ans vont pas retrouver quelque chose
parce qu'à ce moment là rien fait pour
eux personne ne sait aujourd'hui combien
de français sont concernés ils sont en
tout cas suffisamment nombreux pour
avoir obtenu de l'état une enquête
épidémiologique une première alors même
que les experts restent persuadés que le
risque sanitaire n'est pas prouvée la
fréquence du cancer de la thyroïde en
france augmentent elles augmentent
depuis plus de vingt ans c'est à dire
bien avant l'accident de tchernobyl pour
des raisons qu'on ne comprend pas bien
pour deux raisons ce ne sont
manifestement pas lié à l'accident de
tchernobyl les autorités sanitaires de
l'époque ont masqué la réalité celle
d'aujourd'hui ne peuvent faire
l'économie de la vérité
quinze ans après l'accident tout est
préférable à l'incertitude